in mathematics in particular we think
it's wise to credit are co-authors at
the beginning of the lecture before
everybody falls asleep and also also for
reasons I can't quite put my finger on
we don't usually show photographs of our
co-authors so this works joined with
Nick and it's part of a rather amorphous
collaboration that we've had going for a
long time and what I'm going to talk
about involves stuff done by Durham
Kelleher who is a computer scientist
which is the only computing aspect of
this talk Daniel strongly no almandine
vapor and paying you and all of these
people have either been graduate
students or postdocs in Oxford in the
last few years so what I want to talk
about is a bit different from what
you've been hearing about I want to talk
about the interaction between selection
and genetic drift for populations that
are living in a special continuum and in
order to do that of course the first
thing I need is a decent model for
genetic drift in a spatial continuum
which is not something that's so easy to
get a handle on so the first half of the
talk is actually going to be telling you
about that and apologies to people
who've seen me talk about this before so
the basic motivation so this was the
creature that Nick was very excited by
when we first met in the mid-1990s for
this vapid estrus and what was pointed
out to me was that most of the classical
models of population genetics
incorporate spatial structure by
supposing that the population is
subdivided into inter deems living at
the vertices of a graph and once
individuals in the population can move
around by moving only along the edges of
that graph now this is where Buddhism of
pedestrians I stole this from the
internet we think it's been rich of
Nicholas's website and try as I might I
cannot see this as a nice discrete grant
so the question is can we actually
modeled directly populations in a
spatial continuum so the mathematical
challenge that was posed to me a long
time ago by Nick was to find a
consistent forward in time model for the
way that the population evolves but of
course a backwards in time model for the
genealogical trees relating individuals
in a sample from the population so that
we could in principle compares a date
I can assure you there will be no data
in this talk but we could in principle
compare the data so malecon right almost
solved this problem in the 1940s right
so they suppose that their population
they were working with populations
distributed on the whole of two
dimensional Euclidean space or one
dimensional Euclidean space that will
stick with two dimensions and I suppose
the initial population was distributed
as a price on point process with
constant intensity what does that mean
it just means if you look in any region
the number of individuals living there
as a plus on random variable with a
parameter proportional to the area of
the region and you can think of those
individuals are just having thrown down
uniformly on that region ok so you've
got something that's very evenly
distributed somehow over the plane and
their population evolved in discrete
generations and each individual leaves
behind a price on a number of offspring
they like pass on with meme one and the
offspring choose their location just
according to an independent Gaussian
pick around the location of the parent
and not unreasonably when you look at it
malecon rights assumed that this plus on
distribution and I started with this
nice constant intensity distribution i
started with would be preserved by this
dynamic so my population would always
look nice and evenly spreading across
space and under that assumption of
course they didn't have access to DNA in
those days but they did talk about the
probability of identity it's under that
assumption would write down a recursion
for the probability of identity of two
individuals sampled at a given distance
from this population and this is food so
this is assuming that individuals in
each each individual in each generation
has some small probability of mutating
to a type different from its parent okay
and this leads to the right Malik a
formula which is a very powerful thing
but unfortunately felsenstein observed
that there's a bit of an issue with the
right Malik oh model or rather the right
Malik Oh assumptions an easy way to see
it is to actually look at a simulation
so this is something Jerome did any nice
pictures are due to Jerome remember the
word nice so he started with a large
Taurus
and he's thrown down a thousand points
so my plus-one process happen to have a
thousand individuals in it and he shall
thrown them down uniformly at random
right there's my price on starting
condition and then he allows the right
Malik a dynamics to go on so each
individual and each generation leaves
behind a price on one number of
offspring and they just choose a
location according to a Gaussian
distribution around the location of the
parent and after ten generations this is
what it looks like so the population
size is still pretty close to a thousand
it's not really changed very much so
that bits all right but it doesn't look
so evenly spread anymore right there's a
lot of white space beginning to appear
after a hundred generations population
size still pretty close to a thousand
but lots of white space and if you
remember we're working on a torus you
can see we've really only got one large
clump during here an hour for a thousand
populations as her generations my
population is noticed that actually the
total size is given by a critical
branching process at a better die out
sooner or later and it's got down to 300
and not long after this it really does
die out but you can see that at this
point it really is just one cluster it's
become very very clustered so fails
ensign observed this clamping effect on
all of our one or r2 and he said well
okay maybe we should work on a torus
maybe it's because we're working on all
of Euclidean space and nothing lives on
all of Euclidean space but we can see
that that doesn't work because we've
still got this this difficulty and also
the population size is going to be a
critical branching process so eventually
it's going to die out until that's all
right let's let's specify let's suppose
that somehow the total population size
is exogenously specified well we can see
that's not going to work either because
if we look back at what happened at x 10
and 100 the population size really
haven't changed very much if I
conditioned my population size to be a
thousand I'd still get the same picture
I'm still getting this clumping
phenomenon and at that point he gave up
and he famously called very famous paper
in 1975 and dubbed the problem the pain
in the Taurus and the lesson that we
learned from the pain in the torus is
that if we assume individuals in our
population somehow reproduce
independently of one another and they
don't sense the local population density
then inevitably we get clumping
so if we want to overcome that clumping
and models have to have some sort of
local regulation and the classical
stepping stone model has exactly that
because it assumes the population size
in each team is fixed and that's the
strongest local regulation you could
think of but we'd like to do something
that's actually in a spatial continuum
which also has a local regulation as a
huge mathematical literature on this and
lots and lots of people have proposed
models at varying degrees of complexity
that incorporate local regulation and
have some sort of stationary
distribution but the problem is that
analytically they're completely
intractable and in particular we are
unable to write down what those
genealogical trees that we want to
compare our models to are actually going
to look like okay so those clumps become
arbitrarily dense and arbitrary big so
actually your population really piles up
and it's so you want something that you
really want some kind of a stationary
distribution over the timescales you're
looking at so there has to be some kind
of individual that has the either
repulsion or the most natural thing to
do is to suppose that the reproductive
success of somebody living in a crowded
region is lower than the reproductive
success of somebody's living somewhere a
lot of resources right density yeah
density-dependent regulation absolutely
okay so here's a really really naive
model to illustrate how we can actually
arrive at something which is
analytically tractable and may I
reassure you that actually lots of other
local structures would lead to the same
limit that I'm going to describe but
let's that some let's pretend we're
right in Monaco and let's try and do
everything based on price on processes
so I'm going to start with a price on
process of constant intensity exactly
like right and ma'lik oh but now
reproduction is not going to be based on
individuals it's going to be based on
events this is the the key way to
overcome the pain in the Taurus so I
have to have some formula because I'm a
mathematician but so at some rate I
throw points down I throw I'm going to
throw balls down onto the
throw discs down onto the plane and that
rate is driven by what we call a price
on point process when an event I'm going
to do it in such way that everything's
translation invariant and time
homogeneous when an event is throwing
down when one of these discs is thrown
down if there's no one living there I
don't do anything but if there are an
individuals living there this is what I
do so if I had a more modern computer
I'd also have a pointer um first of all
I choose a parent uniformly at random
from the individuals that were in the
ball so I've colored that parent magenta
okay and then each individual is a
notice first of all that your chance
being picked as parent is inversely
proportional to the local population
density right so your chance of being a
parent in the event is reduced if you're
living in a crowded region now i'm going
to pick independently every time an
eventful as a probability and that
probability you I've denoted it is going
to tell me the proportion of individuals
that are going to be replaced in this
reproduction event so each individual is
going to flip a coin that comes up heads
with probability you and if it gets
ahead it dies okay so thins the
population and then I'm going to throw
down new individuals at the same type as
the parent these are they and they're
going to be born in order to replenish
this Poisson process they're also going
to be born according to a Poisson
process just within the ball no one out
outside the ball and because i will have
removed approximately lambda u times the
areas of all individuals i will replace
by lambda u times the area of the ball
individuals okay and i think there's one
more they are I've killed dozens and
this is the state after the reproduction
event now if I allowed birth from
nowhere so if I hadn't said if a region
is empty do nothing but instead I've
said if a region is empty i'll still
allow myself to throw down some
Offspring then this process would have
the distribution I started with the
price on point process with constant
intensity as a stationary distribution
so this is as close to right Malik o as
you could possibly want to be
however because I insist that you can't
have births from nowhere the Poisson
process isn't a stationary distribution
but it almost is right so if lambda is
big enough this thing does have a nice
sort of stationary distribution we don't
get uncontrolled clumping and we can
write down the genealogical trees but
the problem is again because regions can
and do become empty those slightly
cumbersome expressions that we get for
the genealogical trees but when you
examine them closely you realize that
actually if you forgot about the
possibility of things getting empty or
if mathematically you like this lambda
go to infinity so that regions never do
become empty they're very very stable so
the genealogical trees for a moderate
value of lambda so for example so that
the average number of individuals in a
ball would be about five are
extraordinarily close to the
genealogical trees that I get by
actually had an infinite intensity
because it's really the genealogical
trees I'm interested in we going to pass
to the lander equals infinity limit
right okay so I'm just trying to compete
with Nick for complicated expressions so
now the object we're going to look at is
what mathematically you obtained by
letting lambda tend to infinity and what
it does is at each time T and point X it
specifies a probability measure on a
tight space so k here is just a space of
tights in a moment that's just going to
be two types an interpretation is if I
were able to sample an individual from
the point X at time T their type would
be determined by taking a pic from that
probability measure row of TX so it's
just telling us the distribution of
tights in our population as time goes
forward and how does it change with time
well again I use this plus on point
process of events so I throw down disks
in a homogeneous way and at a constant
rate when it is false first of all I
gonna pick a location for the parent
that's just going to be uniformly
distributed on the disk because I I
don't know where individuals are lambdas
infinite now so they're sort of evenly
spread everywhere across here so the
location of the parent is going to be
uniform I pic i ascertain the
type of the parent by taking a pic from
the probability measure at the point
where the parent was this was the point
Z immediately before the event right
that gives me a type and that tells me
that all offspring of this event we're
tied k so I have to update my sampling
probabilities so for each point in this
fall each point why in this ball
immediately after the event if I sample
an individual the probability there an
offspring is you and therefore their
type is K and that's what this means the
probability they were not an offspring
that they were already there and they
just survived the event is 1 minus you
and then their distribution is
determined by sampling as if the event
had never happened and this gives us a
way of modeling the way allele
frequencies evolve forwards in time okay
well that's kind of complex stuff but it
turns out that the backwards in time
processes of genealogy is actually a
little bit easier to get your head
around so again I'm showing off this is
some proving I'm a mathematician and can
use later let's think about a single
ancestral lineage so if I take an
individual a sample an individual from
the population nothing's going to happen
to it until it's covered by one of these
reproduction events when that happens it
has probability you of being an
offspring of the event and if it's an
offspring of the event its parent was it
the location of the parent of the event
which is just a uniformly distributed
point on the event and that means I can
it's actually a little single lineage is
just going to move around according to a
continuous time and space random walk
it's just going to jump to the load
whenever it's hit by a reproduction
event it jumps the location of the
parents and that's something i can write
down exactly the distribution of and
that's all this says but different
lineages are not going to evolve
independently of one another and in
particular lineages could coalesce when
they hit by the same event so this is
meant to all the green circles are meant
to represent lineages immediately before
the events i trace backwards in time
lineage is not hit by the event don't
change but if this event
compasses a number of ancestral lineages
I can have multiple lineages being
offspring of the event and therefore
merging into the common parent so I get
coalescence events when individuals are
encompassed by the same reproduction
event and those car lessons events may
not be Kingman writing it may not just
be paralyzed it may be multiple mergers
okay so what you've got is a system of
random Walker's jumping around according
to continuous time random walks with
continuous jumps I with continuous some
distribution of junk size as well and
when they're encompassed by the same
event so when they're close enough
together to be hit by the same event
they have some chance coalesce and that
turns out to be a very analytically
tractable process that we can study and
we can use it's a great deal about
allele frequencies in the population now
I should emphasize that you know I've
presented this with disks and it in a
very sort of way always replacing things
uniformly across the disk it's a
framework what's important is that
reproduction is based on events not on
individuals as soon as you've done that
you've overcome the pain in the Taurus
and then you can do whatever you like
but the sort of results I'm interested
in are going to be robust to whatever
your choice of local reproduction
mechanism is I'm not pretending this is
how population's evolved but I am
pretending it picks up some of the key
features of the way populations above
okay and I told why the v1 bit of data
in the form of a picture at the end of
halftime okay so I wanted to investigate
or in my interest was in investigating
the interaction between genetic drift
and now this is meant to be a model of
genetic drift for a population in a
spatial continuance I've got a neutral
model I wanted to look at the
interaction of that with selection so
I'm going to take a very simple form of
selection I'm going to space like there
are lots lots ways I could do it- notice
my population has just two types there's
land capital A and then instead of
thinking in terms of probability
measures at each point in space I can
just specify what's the proportion of
mine if I sample an individual from X at
time T the probability its type little a
is going to
written w of TX but we won't use the
notation very much and to introduce
selection I'm just going to wait the way
in which I choose the parent right so
the standard sort of where you introduce
selection into a mile model that I guess
we've heard about already this afternoon
even if we didn't get a boot camp so I'm
going to insist when I have a
reproduction event up till now I just
sampled an individual uniformly at
random from all those present in the
ball but now i'm going to give the
capital a guys awake 1 plus s another
late guys await 1 and s here is just a
small positive parameter right just a
standard way we introduce selection in
the modern model so if a reproduction
event affects a ball centered on exit of
radius R and at the time when the
reproduction event hits the proportion
of little Ariel's in that boilers w bar
then the probability the offspring earth
time little a is going to be just given
by this ratio okay now s is going to be
small but you know you're only meant to
see 10 time s isn't it to be small so I
might as well expand this guy as a
geometric series and I'm going to throw
away tons of order s squared and then
this is kind of nice it means when an
event falls I can think of it as being
of one of two types so I can say well
with probability 1 minus s my event is
like my neutral events that I had before
and the chance of choosing a little a
offspring is just w bar on the other
hand with probability s it's a selective
event and then the chance having a
little a offspring is w bar squared and
how am I going to make that happen well
i'm going to sample to potential parents
and only if they'll both type literally
do I have a little late do I have a
little a offspring and then I just
choose one of those potential parents at
random if one of them or two of them are
tight capital a then I choose at random
among the capital a's for the parent so
that just didn't just make sure that i
have this probability of sampling and it
also gives me a choice of parent a nice
thing about working with the Poisson
processes that actually then we can
think of selection that
future events and selective events as
being driven by two independent Poisson
processes neutral events falling at rate
1 minus s unselective events falling to
read proportional to s ok let's see
right I'm going to be very brave and see
if my computer's feeling up to playing a
video so quick priority about we're
inclined so here's the little a
population we seeded it with some
capital a guys and this is just how is
selectively advantageous and Leo will
spread out and you can see that it
gradually develops into what you'd
expect an expanding weight right at the
point of view of the genealogies all the
interesting stuff is happening around
here right that's where are we going to
get interesting effects from the
selection and now unfortunately we're on
a torus and we've spilled over the edge
but that's how do you stop this thing
once it started it won't stop right but
that that's the sort of picture we get
for the way that the allele frequencies
spread out now I said all the
interesting genial a genealogical stuff
is going to is going to arise because of
what happens when we're in this noisy
very noisy way from here things get a
little bit confounded by the geometry
when you look at a mutation that sense
of spreading in a circular wave so to
make our lives easier we we're going to
think about a flat way if we're actually
not going to think we're not going to
solve the problem of the genealogy but i
just want to show you the kind of thing
that happens so remember i said all the
nice pictures were due to jerome this
beauty is due to Nick so we're not quite
sure what it's off I did ask him if
anything
um but the idea is that this is a
wavefront but progressed in this
direction I assume that these are
colored at the end a bit for artistic
reasons and this is made to give you
some idea of where individuals were
descended from so actually this was a
stepping stone model it wasn't the model
I just showed you and what you can see
is that you get sort of a lot of
lineages a lot of the stuff in the front
tugged into small numbers of kind of
bottlenecks as you go backwards in time
and actually I think we've got with
actually perilously close to
understanding exactly how to model this
but what you can see is that things are
a non trivial things are really quite
complicated alright so I can't tell you
exactly how to solve that but how would
we I mean you know how do you try and
get a hold of the genealogy during a
selective sweet well if you're coupe and
Griffiths or kaplan and hudson or indeed
does some years ago you try and look at
the way that the allele frequencies
evolved as you go backwards in time and
you do a coalescent in a random
background can't do that here because we
can't reverse the process of allele
frequencies in a spatial context that is
very much harder we don't have a good
enough understanding in fact the way
that the wave is going forwards in time
tivi had to say very much about what it
does backwards in time the other sort of
the methodology that some Bob Griffiths
and I pushed and also Donnelly and
Stevens I think was using a kind of
proxy for radial frequencies as you go
backwards in time which we call virtual
lineages again we can't do it because we
don't know enough about the distribution
of all your frequencies as you go
forwards and backs in time and how they
evolve so I was reminded by Conrad who's
probably here somewhere that Nick and I
have an ancient manuscript called
distinguishing causes of reduced genetic
diversity which we never published and I
think the reason we never published it
was because we realized we simply
couldn't and so and so what the question
that I decided that I would try and
solve instead with a graduate student
Daniel Australia know was to try and
understand when there would be any
patterns that we could actually see in
our data and to do that we're going to
use something which
you'll probably throw up your hands in
horror / because it's a spatial analog
of the ancestral selection graph now the
ancestral selection graph isn't terribly
practical even when there's no space
because the number of lineages can grow
very very quickly in the ancestral
selection graph so you can imagine it's
even worse in space but one of the
advantages of hiring someone like Jerome
calicos he can actually simulate these
things but we're just going to use it as
an analytic tool so um what's it going
to look like so what what the ancestral
selection graph is going to do for us is
it's going to at least include the
ancestry of a sample from my population
so remember what the genealogical trees
look like in the neutral case we had
individuals move around according to
random walks and when they were
encompassed by the same event then they
could coalesce right well the neutral
events that we have and we've split our
events Nyota two sorts neutral events
and selective events so neutral events
that's fine it's exactly as before but
at a selective events both I've just
looking at a single linear chat the
selective event I can't decide which of
the two potential parents I picked is
the real parent unless I know their
types and find out their types I'm going
to have to trace further back in time
until I've got some idea what the
distribution of types in the population
is so what I do it's entirely analogous
to the ancestral selection graph that
cronin night house are introduced in the
absence of space is that when i get to a
selective event i follow to potential
ancestral lineages now I go back to some
time in the past and I can resolve and
assign tight to the ancestral lineage
potential ancestral lineages that are
around and I can move back through the
tree resolving who was actually the
parent at each of these events so here
we have an event where these guys were
all offspring of the event but I
replaced them not by one lineage as we
did for the neutral events but by two
okay so i have a branching a coalescing
structure one thing that makes this kind
of fun actually is that at least if i
want to know things like what's the
probability of sampled individualist i'm
a little a well only a
if and only if all the lineages in this
potential the set of potential ancestors
are of type little a at every previous
time and that actually allows me to say
things about the way that the allele
frequency spread forwards in space but
let's use it to say to answer this
question you know when I got any hope of
actually seeing a selective sweet so of
course if we if the selector sweet
sweeps through a population we no longer
have any variability at the selected
lockers and so we're going to try and
detect it by looking for patterns of
neutral variation close by and that
means that if I'm going to see the
effect of selection those patterns of
neutral variation have to be distorted
right and neutral variation is then
going to set the time scale for the sort
of coalescent process that I'm looking
at so I need that the coalescent process
let's suppose there's no recombination
forget recombination so suppose that the
coalescent at the selected lockers is
going to suppose I'm going to see any
interesting patterns of the neutral
lockers I need my coalescent at the
selected lockers to look different from
what it would have done under neutrality
in the sense that when I look at it when
I look for neutral mutations on it I see
something different so that means when I
look at it over time scales that are set
by the Nutri mutation rate so times both
water 1 over mu it's got to look
different now in a spatial context those
time scales also dictate a spatial scale
right so if I'm looking at ancestry over
a timescale of order 1 over mu and
asking is it looking any different from
the neutral case then the spatial scales
over which I expect to be looking well
remember a single ancestral lineage was
basically following a random walk so I
have to look over spatial scales of the
order 1 over square root of mute so
that's what we're going to do we're
going to actually look at our ancestral
selection graph over timescales 1 over
mu and spatial scales 1 over root me and
just this comment that because mutation
rates are going to be low
this means i'm looking at large temporal
and spatial scales and scaling limits so
what we're actually in do is look at the
skating limit but scaling limits are
wonderfully robust so the fact i took
this very special model with disc
replacement and all this kind of stuff
isn't going to matter there are a vast
array of there is a vast array of other
models which incorporate the same basic
getting over the pain in the Taurus and
a bit of selection which would give you
the same limit okay so I guess I'm just
used by that the scale is 1 over square
root of MU since you have this
propagating wave what associated with
selection well because i'm really
looking at a neutral locker sorry so
that you're interested I mean where are
you going to see most of it anyway look
at your galston I mean you're gonna see
everything on square root of me the wave
sweet-sour right yeah yeah yeah yeah but
that's not but that's not all that but
the you'll see that you won't I mean if
you don't see anything on the scon this
girl you went down a long scale the the
density of the wave at the front so okay
you're right most particle is spreading
out a long way but most your wave is
still focused around wherever it began
so you're still going to see the
interesting patterns you're going to
look at where you would expect to see
your neutral mutation and you're going
to see them most of the patterns are
going to be think about a single single
selectively advantageous mutation
arising you've got this Gaussian yes
you're going to see somebody way out
here but most guys are still going to be
in here so we can expect high density if
you actually do the calculation with
your logistic control and so on most of
it is still looking like a Brownian
motion around where you began it's just
it's going to be at higher frequency
there so we can we can talk about it
okay so we're going to look at this
limit under small population density so
what do I mean by that the classical
world will come with high population
that's in a minute small population
density is just saying if I'm looking in
a spatial continuum then
number of individuals living in one of
these regions is not necessarily going
to be particularly big in particular
it's not going to be infinite which is
what the standard if deterministic
differential equation models assume so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to fix
the proportion of individuals that are
replaced an event that something between
zero and one so it might be one percent
it might be ten percent it might be
fifty percent but it's fixed I'm not
going to let it go to zero as I passed
on my scaling limit and let's just go
respond to the idea that your local
population density is not going to be
infinite and then we ask what's that
what's the chance that the ancestral
selection graph is going to look
different on the spatial and temporal
scale so I've set n 4 1 over mu to see
me having to say 1 over mu all the time
so if I'm looking at time scales 1 over
mu times T so n times t and space tech
scales square root of n times X when
will I be able to see that my ancestral
selection graph is different from what i
have seen under neutrality in other
words when will i actually detect any of
those branches remember I'm looking
whenever I have a selective event I get
a branch in my ancestral selection graph
and it turns out to depend on dimension
so let's have a look in high dimensions
first I know not many populations live
in at least three dimensions but it's
the easiest case to deal with so if your
dimension that's bigger or equal to 3
when we get to one of these branching
events we have two parents and those
parents are born at order one apartment
positive positive probability they're
going to get far enough apart that they
can no longer be encompassed by a single
event and then there's positive
probability because interventions bigger
equal three random walk is transient
there's positive probability they will
actually escape from one another and
never see each other again an in that
case I'm actually going to be able to
detect that there is a difference i do
have a difference between my ancestral
selection graph and my just ordinary
coalescent so in order to see a
difference I just need to see order one
of those branching events and that means
that my selection coefficient has to be
on order 1 over X remember
timescales n times t and these come in a
trade s so I just need the selection in
the mutation to be on the same order
exactly as if there are no spatial
structure right in two dimensions it's
slightly different because random walk
in two dimensions is recurrent so if I
start to random walks a distance or two
one for each other they will come back
and see each other again they'll come
back and meet again and have eventually
coalesce so the real question is are
they going to be able to get as far
apart as the square root of n before
they come back and coalesce and for a
single pair of random walkers the chance
of that is order 1 over log in so I'm
going to have to have many more branches
I'm going to have to have order of log n
branches before I actually see any of
these branching events when I'm looking
out that scales of autoroute n so don't
get to order routine I'm just not going
to see them because that's the spatial
scale over which I'm looking at things
so that means that my selection
coefficient has to be quite a lot bigger
if I'm going to see a distinction
between the ancestral selection graph
and just ordinary neutrality so if I'm
going to detect selection it's going to
have to be stronger and this is really
the genetic drift it's really because
that when in two dimensions this does
not enough space so solar even a
selectively advantageous individual
finds himself or herself competing with
close family and and behaving almost as
if in neutrality much sooner okay this
is the this is two dimensions one
dimension things are even worse because
the chance that too one dimensional
random walkers get to distance root n
before they come back together is on the
order of 1 over root ale so I bit
ability to actually see anything is
highly dependent on dimension which I
think it's actually quite interesting
okay that I've put the scaling limits
one it's nice to make contact with what
with some more classical models Fisher
was always right at some level it turns
out that if we allow the density of our
population to go to infinity which
corresponds to rescaling that impact
parameter that you to go to 0 then we
can obtain the standard classical fish
PP equation and in one dimension with
can even put a noise term in there this
alpha is just because one of the things
you can do at this model is that you can
say well how about having not just these
small scale things which I'm thinking of
as modeling sort of local reproduction
events but how about putting large scale
events in as well logica scale
extinction recolonization type events
and it turns out if you do that in the
right way then then you can obtain a
slightly different scaling limit in
which the laplacian is replaced by
what's called a symmetric stable process
and this equation has been studied
reasonably extensively especially in the
physics literature okay I just wanted to
put I'm just writing up the paper on
this is one of the reasons I put the
slide in but I just wanted to show we
can get back the standard for sure k PP
a quick could you do it with the noise
oh yeah with the alpha yeah yeah but
it's always the same noise term and
that's what's interesting and that's
because what's happened also this this
same time here so you don't see the
large-scale events remembering we're
letting the population density go to
infinity the large-scale events don't
feature in either the Selective term or
the genetic drift and this is
essentially because they're not the
large-scale events don't fall fast
enough then that they're not able to
beat beat the small scale events
internally not in here so all they do is
they leave individuals around
essentially one at a time which is some
first sight slightly surprising and then
you think of it harder and it's it
becomes clear away it's true you can do
if you try to do things with only small
neighborhood size you get a completely
different result okay so this is all
mathematical toys right so i just wanted
to show you some circumstantial evidence
that the kind of genealogies that we
would write down for this model may not
be a million miles away from the kind of
genealogies that you'd actually see if
you were looking at a real population so
this was the easiest piece of data for
me to get my hands on Kevin foster from
Oxford sent me this picture it's
pseudomonas aeruginosa and the
Superman's two different colors green
and blue I believe
and what's happened is at time zero
nutrient a nutrient infused dish has
been seated with a mixture of the two
strains which are equally fit but
they're expanding outwards now one way
you can think of a population which is
expanding outwards is of individuals
which are actually fit they've got some
some selective advantage of being how do
I put this you can think of range
expansion as an extreme case of
selective advantage and in nature you
might think that you have a population
invading a less fit population here
we've got the extreme case of an
infinite selective advantage in the
sense that you're moving into empty
space but you can see use the same
models to model it okay so what you see
here is you don't get the whole
genealogy of course you don't but you do
at least see some caricature of what's
going on so for example all these guys
out here must be descended from some
blue guy back here right so you least
get some idea of what the genealogy is
by looking at these stables yeah just
like a single right here yeah you just
can't quite see he's there but he's very
rare it's it's just stock us the city I
mean you're just sitting you're sitting
on the edge so if you happen to be lucky
enough to have made it to the edge of
this kind of a way you've got a
reasonable you're just trying to spread
out if you might just get ahead of the
pack you you spread out really quite
quickly and it's too it's just someone
here has been really lucky and it's just
chance do you got an awful lot of trials
around here there an awful lot of
bacteria mother's so it's like doing
young it's great in a way because you're
doing probability theory when you've got
an essentially infinitely big sample and
so you see everything that could happen
will happen okay so that's what bacteria
do and that's what simulating our model
does which doesn't look too bad and in
fact we produce that before Kevin sent
us there
your servant was fortuitous that he
chose the right colors lesson so I
didn't say I cheated but I didn't cheat
in the way that you expected me to cheat
so of course I cheated to get the
picture that looks quite as good as this
or other Jerome cheated but he didn't
cheat by doing lots and lots and lots of
repetitions of the simulation still we
got the right one because as I say we
had this before we had that but what he
did do and that's the actual outcomes
the simulation and because it's so sharp
it doesn't look so good so what he did
was being a computer scientist he knows
these things there is software which
will make a sharp image look as though
you didn't have quite such a high
resolution camera and so all he did was
he replaced the Charlie by the blurred
image and it looked much better ok
there's a serious point now in a serious
point is that we're really not trying to
capture exactly what's going on in these
bacterial colonies we're trying to
capture broad features and I think this
is circumstantial evidence admittedly
but circumstantial evidence that we are
capturing some broad features because
that is actually what the bacteria are
doing and we're not modeling that we're
not pretending to model that but we are
capturing some how some of the broad
features and its spite of having started
late I'm only finishing a little bit
late thank you yes
necessary things going on too yeah you
can't guess so if you want consistent
forwards and back buttons my models we
have to have yeah but actually
well that's actually how we got the
right number set so I said we'd already
got this in this case the number of
number of sectors that we have is just a
ratio of the initial droplet and the
size the ball it's like the
deterministic function of those two
essentially it's not so mystic it's
random but it's very close to discover
still its escape we need you but one of
the reasons for a noun different sizes
that ball was because we were initially
interested in including these
large-scale extinction recolonization
events because we're interested in
incorporating some of the demographic
history Thanks so in principle one of
the more serious things that you could
in principle do with this model is then
you could do simulations conditional
upon quite complex demographic histories
so you could put in ice ages and things
into a simulation it doesn't have to be
formal to communicate your night and I
think Nick had this idea he wants to
debunk my lads say this you wanted to
debunk phylogeography by actually doing
things traditionally simulating
conditional in their condo on the
history so if I'm thinking about this is
hitchhiking I'm thinking about these
different sectors are responding to
different recombinant have
types which have served along with the
illegal grades so in that case do I
think about me this time scale in which
i'm looking at instead of being
parameterised by one on the intention
being one under the combination well in
this case they're not bringing snow
recombination bit more contrite a
capacity yeah if that's right so if you
have to have both right so the mutation
rate is telling you whether or not
you've got a chance of seeing anything
and then the recombination rate will
tell you how far away from the selected
locus you can go and still expect to see
something you still need the mutation
rate in there some works it's a no
mutations on your genealogy not and see
if those mutations can be deep friend
time right they can be they can either
native ev'ry beaches around so sure but
it's too far back it's not going to give
you a signal
okay so thanks to allison unto every one
soft moon